[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
what did
the five fingers say to the face
well
i did not have the question
of why wasn't will smith on hand at the
trump rally
on my monday morning bingo card
here on the tony michaels podcast as you
know every single weekday noon eastern
11 central nine pacific youtube twitter
twitch and now and now on the midas
touch facebook page we broadcast live
every single weekday live streaming
for your pleasure and boy
boy
boy did the show change
all of a sudden quick and in a hurry
last night
when chris rock decided to make an
offhanded joke about
jada
pinkett smith
and her husband will smith decided to um
violently assault chris rock on stage
now there's a lot of stuff there's a lot
to unpack with the slap
a lot to unpack with the slap and we're
gonna unpack i probably
more than we probably should today there
is a thousand opinions out there on
every side of this issue
i mean
it is going viral people are [ __ ]
pissed they're pissed off at each other
and they're pissed off at will smith
they're pissed off at chris rock they're
pissed off at the academy they're pissed
off but everyone's got someone that
they're [ __ ] pissed off about today
today
they have someone that they're
absolutely [ __ ] pissed off about with
this event
the lapd
there's all kinds of people to be pissed
off about
in this pop pop culture event but let me
tell you something first before we begin
to break down the event that happened
last night on the oscars because i
figured today what we were going to be
talking about was the [ __ ] crazy ass
fascists who are trying to take over our
[ __ ] democracy
that way we don't have we don't have
chris rock presenting at the oscars we
don't have will smith winning an oscar
forget having jada pink at smith at the
oscars they don't want that kind of
stuff
so let's just thank our lucky stars that
those pieces of [ __ ] that were at the
trump rally do not have control of our
democracy yet
mind you because see a lot of people out
there are saying oh you can't tony you
can't focus on the slap
and defend our democracy [ __ ]
that's a bunch of [ __ ]
that's a bunch of [ __ ] nonsense
de-slap the pop culture slap and the
discussion our country is gonna have
over the next 24 hours about how will
smith smack the [ __ ] out of chris rock
because he made a really shitty joke
about his wife a woman who is suffering
from a disease
we're gonna have that discussion and we
get to have that discussion in this
country because we have freedom of
speech
because we have a democracy
that's the thing that we have this is
why it is so [ __ ] important to pay
attention
it's so [ __ ] important to pay
attention and we're gonna break this
down i promise you
from all points of view
from every [ __ ] point we're gonna
just break it down we're gonna go line
by line with this thing
because there's a lot of opinions out
there everyone's [ __ ] got one and
you're gonna disagree with the thousand
of them that are here
because
chris rock is a comedian he made a joke
jada pinkett smith jada pink piket smith
has a disease
that
should not be made fun of in that way
and will smith had a reaction
that he should not have had
it really a [ __ ] mess it's a [ __ ]
mess it's a [ __ ] mess this morning
but let's let's face it let's face it
this pop culture event
in our history which
now will smith his his entire oscar is
tied to him slapping the [ __ ] out of
chris rock and that's chris rock's words
not mine
chris rock literally says
he says he slapped the [ __ ] out of me
that's what he says
he says he slapped the [ __ ] out of me
so we'll break it down i promise as we
go along in the show because we're going
to show that we're going to show the
tape we're going to show
uh several pieces of
evidence i guess
apparently chris rock is not going to
press charges regardless of the evidence
he's not going to press charges
my light is blinking i don't know what
the hell is going on
you see that
oh man
just going gonna have to deal it's live
folks it's live
maybe have to get a new light i don't
know
but we're gonna break it down we're
gonna get it we're gonna break it down
here
and everyone every again everyone has an
opinion on exactly who they're pissed
off at and i'm i'm gonna tell you i'm
gonna tell you that that we are pissed
off every single and every single one of
them now
on american television i was not
watching the oscars i was not watching i
really didn't i mean i knew it was on
but i
no one gave a [ __ ] like who gives a [ __ ]
about the oscars no one really cares i
guess
until will smash will smith smacks the
[ __ ] out of chris rock
some people are even saying it was
staged for that reason alone
is to make sure
that people were paying attention to the
oscars you remember several years ago
uh
warren beatty gave away the wrong
goddamn or the award to the wrong person
you remember that
everyone remembers that oh it got big
that some people are saying it's staged
i don't think it's staged i don't think
it's stage i think that's all [ __ ]
and bogus i don't think it's stage i
don't think will smith would [ __ ]
slap chris rock or chris say you know it
looks like chris rock was
was waiting for the slap but i mean when
a guy swings like that and the guy comes
up on stage and swings like that you you
tend to start to uh
to expect it when the when the hand's
coming around
when the wind-up happens
okay
everybody's here this morning
yeah i i appreciate all the new
listeners hello to everyone out there on
facebook youtube twitch twitter
we appreciate you guys joining us every
single weekday noon eastern eleven
center right here on d tony michael's
podcast
as you know
as you know we are live live streaming
every single weekday
so if you're a new listener here and
this is your first show
don't forget
to subscribe to the youtube channel
go over and and like and follow the
midas touch facebook page where we
stream over there
if you're on twitch make sure you follow
us there and on twitter follow at tony
michael's pod we have a special bonehead
madness this week for you
i don't know if you guys notice the
games or not we we play bonehead of the
week every single week and we put a poll
up on the podcast twitter page for you
all to vote and then on fridays in the
second hour because we do two hours a
day two hours a day
every single weekday
in the second hour on friday we break
down your vote your vote on bonehead of
the week and this week we have a special
bonehead madness that we are doing
this is all thanks to gabe sanchez my
executive producer and co-host which
gabe will join us here at the bottom of
the first hour
you guys should go check it out at the
tony michael's pod the twitter page
the games are up there you can go down
the thread you can you can vote
now now some of the games are over
because the games happen it's a bracket
system and we're gonna have the bone the
bonehead madness winner the champion as
it were and me and gabe will talk a
little more about this
here uh at the top of the first hour
when he joins us
because i know we're gonna get
commentary on the will smith we're gonna
figure out what gabe thinks about this
and where he falls
on the will smith slap
because everyone seems to be falling in
different areas and let me tell you i
actually don't think you you don't have
to fall in one camp or another right
like chris rock chris rock was doing his
job
he made a really shitty joke
whether you like it or not rather rather
you you think it was bad good and
different it was a really shitty joke he
may not have known he may have known who
gives a [ __ ] it was a shitty joke about
a woman who has a disease not not not a
[ __ ] not very good aim with a joke
now rather chris rock knew it or not or
he wrote the joke or not who knows if it
was just in the teleprompter it's at
this point we're not aware of this
and then we have will smith who had a
reaction about chris rock making that
offhanded joke about his wife
which i mean
he's justified and maybe having a
reaction a violent reaction not exactly
justified
not exactly justified to go up on stage
and smack the [ __ ] out of someone
i'm just saying that's chris for oxford
it's not my words he smacked the [ __ ]
out of him that's what he said and we'll
show it here we're gonna show it we're
gonna show it i don't give a [ __ ] we're
gonna show the slap
and then you have and then you have 20
minutes later which is really [ __ ]
weird it's really weird that
that will smith was not removed right
it's really [ __ ] weird apparently
during the break which no one sees is
that chris
excuse me will smith's uh publicist
comes over to talk to him and then
denzel washington talks to him as well
now will smith during his acceptance
speech because this [ __ ] didn't
just slap chris rock last night like
that's not the only thing that happened
he didn't just slap chris rock the
[ __ ] won
an oscar 20 minutes later after he
slapped chris rock
he won and then he gave an acceptance
speech was which was overly long he
really overdid it
i mean honestly is his acceptance speech
was almost as bad if not worse than his
his actions that he took not the slap
but the the yelling because i'm going to
explain the out that chris rock actually
gave will smith because i think chris
rock gave an out to will smith and will
smith did not take it
that's right
chris rock gave will smith and out and
will smith decided not to take it which
is fine that's his choice
he made his bed here
and i think will smith is gonna come out
the worst here but let's let's actually
talk about something that is that is uh
weighing on my mind
he said at the heart of all this
jada is the one who was
she was the butt of the the really
shitty joke right regardless of if it
was funny if it was not you know you can
think whatever you want about the joke
and really you can think whatever you
want about comedians and all that [ __ ]
but here's the thing comedians have a
choice too right comedians have a choice
now rather chris rock wrote the joke or
knew that jada had alopecia is a is a
question
but comedians have a choice they have a
choice of what their aim is in their
jokes
they have a choice of what their aim is
in the joke
they can choose to aim at
jada pinkett smith for her hairstyle
or they could choose not to now whoever
wrote the joke rather it was chris rock
or he just off-handedly said this i
don't think he off-handedly said it i
think it was written and the reason why
i think it was written is because
they went they went and really
and really the the joke before
about penelope cruz was way more
misogynistic
than than the joke about jada pinkett
smith and the gi jane joke 100 percent
was just as distasteful
and her husband
i mean could have been just as pissed
now he understood it was a joke i guess
and went with it and really if you watch
will smith in the clip it seems like he
goes with the jokes until he doesn't
if you watch the clip it's hard to tell
though because they cut away in the
clips from will smith
once the joke is told before he walks up
on stage
now
why is this all important and what does
it have to do with politics what has to
do with pop culture
100 percent has to do with pop culture
and people are going to talk about this
whether we like it or not people are
going to have a an opinion on this
whether we like it or not
well how can we how can we spin this
into our democracy well here's how
here's how you want it you want to get
people to listen to your pro-democracy
message
well the next few days talk about the
slap
talk about the slap
i don't know maybe you just get someone
in a conversation about pop culture
i mean colin kaepernick
kneeled
in solidarity with police violence
against black people
and republicans made it about the
military in the flag
do you see how it works
you see how this stuff works do you see
how messaging works
people aren't interested in politics in
general you have to get him interested
through pop culture how do you think
trump did all this
how do you think trumpism and fascism
has taken hold in this country marjorie
taylor greene stood on stage
that [ __ ] fascist stood on stage this
weekend
and said the words gay people go and gay
men go in girls bathrooms
out of nowhere
out of nowhere talking about bicycles
and electric electric cars as if
bicycles and electric cars
are the liberal enemy of the right or
some [ __ ]
oh don't think we're not gonna talk
about the [ __ ] trump rally we're
definitely gonna talk about the funk and
trump rally today
we can do both see that's how it works
that's how it works in messaging and
politics and discussion and social
issues
you can have all these discussions all
at the same time you don't have to be
distracted
from saving our democracy just because
you need to talk about a pop culture
event that happened
you don't have to
we can choose not to actually we can
choose to tie the two things together in
our messaging
very important
if you're unaware of how fascism and how
trumpism fascism with a manga hat has
taken hold in our country that's how
they did it
that's how they did it wrestle the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life
that's the q anon [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that jenny thomas
the wife of a supreme court justice
believes in this q and on garbage
full stop 100 percent she's a q an honor
you can't convince me otherwise how
could you how could you convince me when
she's texting the chief of staff who has
the ear of the president united states
queuing on conspiracy theories she was
saying that democrats are going to be
taken to gitmo and and under military
tribunals
think about this
this is crazy ass [ __ ]
you know how they did it that's how they
leaked into the mind of jenny thomas
i have several my relatives that have
fallen to q anon i challenge laura
loomer
or no excuse me laura logan
the two could be confused
laura logan this morning she was on some
q and on show we're going to show the
clip i challenged her to come on my show
just to ask her how she felt a q a on
i hear several months ago she tweeted at
me some andy no word salad
this is how they're doing it this is how
they're doing it
there's a crazy ass video mike flynn in
his [ __ ] vehicle over the weekend
and he blurred out the [ __ ] car
it's really weird it's really weird why
he used the blur feature on his car i'm
not really sure you know a lot of people
like use it you know so you can't see
the background at their house or like
their bookshelf what's on their
bookshelf or
you know try to create depth perception
maybe because the background's blurry
i don't know
it's like a you know a camera trick at
best
but mike flynn blurs out the background
and his [ __ ] mercedes or land rover
whatever kind of [ __ ] expensive car
he's driving
i don't know i don't know what he drives
i don't give a [ __ ] really
he gives a [ __ ] clearly because he's
blurring it out
i don't know it's [ __ ] weird i don't
trust a guy i don't trust a guy who uses
a blur feature
on his background when he's in his car
really [ __ ] weird
so we're gonna watch that as well
but this is all relevant
in the day of age of the internet and
communication
and talking about issues and pop culture
again why do you think
you think we're not fighting for pop
culture
you think we're not fighting to have the
oscars
there's a moment at the oscars where the
three hosts stand on stage and start to
sing gay gay gay
and rub it in ronda santa's face
right everyone's talking about the will
smith slap but that moment right there
that moment right there at the oscars
when they're saying gay gay gay gay gay
to rub it in ron desantis face
that moment right there is probably more
critically important
you want to know how you tie
the will smith slap at the oscars to
politics there you go there's your
avenue there's your discussion with your
person that wherever the grocery store
your community center
dares you're in
right there as you're talking about the
will smith's lap you say yeah
yeah that that was so weird that will
smith slap crazy stuff the other thing
that's crazy
is that they had to sing gay gay gay gay
gay on
the oscars because florida's passing
laws discriminate against gay people
that's [ __ ] weird too isn't it
there's your discussion see your inlet
to think to think that the oscars has
nothing to do with politics
is ridiculous
ridiculous to think that pop culture has
nothing to do with politics is [ __ ]
ridiculous
it's ridiculous
and for everyone to be out there saying
that you can't you can't talk about will
smith
and chris rock and the slap and how the
the offhanded joke that chris had with
jada has nothing to do nothing to do
with politics and you can't focus on
that or you'll lose to fight for
democracy
guys
the pop culture event that happened last
night good bad and different no matter
what side you're on who you're pissed
off at rather pissed off at chris pissed
off at will pissed off at the academy
pissed off at mel gibson
whoever you're pissed off at
that's the part that we're fighting for
that's it i know it seems crazy
that we're fighting for for this event
to happen
not specifically
but for the oscars in general
you think under a fascist state that we
would have the oscars that we had last
night
you think we would have the winners that
we had last night
do you think that that event would look
the same
come on now
come on now
don't kid yourself
don't kid yourself
it's real
all right we got a lot of [ __ ] to round
up today a lot of [ __ ] to round up on
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
well and the majority of it has to do
with this
crazy ass [ __ ] that happened at the
oscars last night so
i guess let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back
this is the
shitless roundup where we round up all
the tweety tweets and then trendy trends
of the day
of course
almost the entire tweety tweets and
trinity trends
have to do with
will smith and chris rock of course and
we have some other stuff on the tweety
tweets and trendy trends uh we we have
um uh
florida and texas and that the view
which is it you know what it's all
pretty much will smith and chris rock
almost all of it
almost all of it
is will smith and chris rock but i tell
you what we're gonna do we're gonna go
through the weekend
and we're also going to look at the
trump rally
because i think it's vitally important
that we see what these fascists are
saying you know i say here do not look
away and we cannot look away at what
these [ __ ] idiots are saying
it is very very very important
very important
very important
to see what they said at the trump rally
super important uh let's let's go to the
timeline here
let me make this a little bigger so you
can see
because there are some videos here that
i want to show from the trump rally
let's go down past some of the some of
the nonsense of the
the will smith because we'll get to it
we'll get to it i promise
um
here is one of the grossest parts
of the trump rally
um but if you're if you're not if you're
not really
paying attention
you know a lot of people don't want to
watch the trump rally i said over the
weekend i'd rather eat a big bag of dog
[ __ ] than go to a trump rally
but here's the thing is we have to pay
attention to what these people are doing
and what they're saying
they want to take control of our country
folks
this is they want to be in power they
want to have power over you
they want to be able to tell you what to
do
and create a fascist state i'm not
kidding you this is real they're on the
doorstep folks
and this is who is is on the doorstep
we have marjorie taylor green here you
can barely see over the lectern
spewing her [ __ ] bigotry i mean
they're not even it's not even quiet
part anymore
you know they're not even using the
trope of transgender people in bathrooms
they're going straight at pete but a
judge going i don't understand this
really how bicycles and electric cars
have anything to do with gay men going
into girls bathrooms i don't understand
this this is a trope by the way this is
the trope that all gay uh well all lgbtq
community members
but specifically in this clip pete buda
judge who is a gay man
are pedophiles child child molesters
that's his trope
that's the disgusting [ __ ] vile trope
the fascist trope
really honestly this comment right here
i think is grounds to remove her from
congress
that's right i said it this comment this
comment of hate
and the the to try to stoke violence
against
a [ __ ] government official
is grounds for removal
if not at least an ethics
investigation into marjory taylor greene
and what else she has said privately
and publicly
about members of the lgbtq community
and i think that this is another reason
why we have to
we have to codify the protection of
lgbtq
people in our constitution women people
of color
and lgbtq people human [ __ ] beings
need to have all the protections that
everyone else has in this country
from people like this
and the people they stoke
to violence
everyone wants to talk about the
violence
that will smith ensued last night
on chris rock on stage on the oscars
but this is the type of violence
that can tear apart our democracy
the will smith chris rock thing is just
a discussion we're gonna have
without making sure that these people
aren't in power we don't get to have the
discussion
about chris rock and will smith
and the slap
got it let's listen to this vile piece
of [ __ ] do not look away i say that all
the time do not look away we have to
know what they're saying
don't say oh i don't want to watch
anything i don't want to watch
anything
from the trump rally you're giving these
people fodder you're giving them air
time listen sunlight is the best
disinfectant especially for these vile
pieces of [ __ ] and these bigots
how else would you know how else will
the country know who they're voting for
who they're supporting you think there's
people out there who who who who love
marjorie taylor green who don't know she
says this that there are people out
there
there are people out there that love
marjory taylor green that have no idea
that she's saying this [ __ ]
guarantee it 100 percent
just because she's a trump supporter and
she says america first i like her
[Music]
100 percent they'd say that they know
hell yes
here's the other secret
there's a lot of people out there that
love her and support her because she
says this [ __ ]
that's the part that we can't undo
we can't undo that part
we can't get rid of people's ideas
no matter how big it they are
but we don't have to elect these people
to run our governments
let's listen to this vile piece of [ __ ]
and you know what
pete butterjudge can take his electric
vehicles and his bicycles and he and his
husband can stay out of our girls
bathrooms
what the [ __ ] does that mean
let's break it down a bit okay
let's break it down a bit
number one
why is electric vehicles and bicycles
the liberal enemy what the [ __ ] is she
talking about number one
i understand
if
someone out there is against electric
vehicles because
there is there is this math that people
do about electric vehicles that a lot of
our electricity that these cars would
run on
is actually produced by fossil fuel in
this country a lot of it
a lot
is produced by fossil fuel whether you
like it or not that's how it's a lot of
it's done that's kind of the whole
purpose of talking about more green
energy right
like that's the whole purpose
so that we can do that
but here she is making bicycles
this is the bicycles
who doesn't remember riding a [ __ ]
bicycle when you were a kid
and having fun do i mean jesus christ
that was some of the that was some of
the best times i had
scrape i'm scraping my knee banging my
head why do you think i am the way i am
today
because of the bicycle no helmet by the
way
back then we didn't wear [ __ ] helmets
and apparently marjory taylor green
had several bicycle accidents
but why are bicycles the enemy here
why and what in the actual [ __ ] does
electric vehicles and bicycles have to
do with bathrooms
what does it have to do with it not a
goddamn thing
not a goddamn thing the reason why
marjorie taylor green is saying this
type of [ __ ] is because she [ __ ]
hates gay people she [ __ ] hates lgbtq
people and she wants them to the gas
chambers got it
you don't think they'll come after you
you don't think you're next
listen she's telling you outright
she's telling you outright
she's saying it out in the [ __ ] open
oh
gay men go into little girls bathrooms
which is a [ __ ] trope a [ __ ] lie
and she needs to be removed for congress
for saying that [ __ ]
at least have an ethics investigation
into her ass today
[ __ ] today
for inciting violence on the lgbtq moon
community
hate speech is what it is
it's a [ __ ] lie
but to tie it to bicycles and electric
cars this is important people this is
really [ __ ] important you may say
tony why is bicycles and bathrooms such
an important issue
she's sending a signal
that it's not just about gay people
being
openly gay
it's about anyone who believes in any
liberal ideas
electric cars bicycles
they're the enemy and the people who
ride bicycles
the people who ride bicycles go into
girls bathrooms that's what she's
[ __ ] saying
that's what the [ __ ] she's saying that's
a message he's sending this [ __ ]
fascist
i'm not a fan i'm not i don't i'm not a
nazi i don't i did no idea who nick
fuentes is i had no idea it was a nazi
rally i had no clue
no clue it was a nazi rally shut the
[ __ ] up
you goddamn right you knew it was a nazi
rally and this is a nazi rally this save
america [ __ ]
save america from what bicycles
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
these people are coming
for you
not just not just people of color not
just
people in the lgbtq community they're
coming for you
too
and they're coming for your community
they're coming for your job they're
coming for your church they're coming
for your [ __ ] school they're coming
for you
they want to take our democracy and our
country away from us our way of life
she's talking about bicycles as if it's
the liberal enemy folks
that's how far down this rabbit hole
they already are
we're not even to 2024 yet we're not
even really in the actual 2022 cycle
like the general of the midterm
we're only in the primaries
and this stupid [ __ ] idiot is talking
about bicycles as if they're some kind
of enemy of the state
i'm telling you they're coming for you
they're coming for you do your kids ride
bicycles
do your kids ride bicycles
i don't know do your kids own buy my
kids on bikes
my kids own bikes
think about it think about what she's
saying here it's very [ __ ] important
don't look away you have to see what
they're saying so many people say oh
tony why do you give these people a
platform a platform she's standing on
stage
in front of
dozens of people
there's a whole crowd
crowd size thing with this [ __ ] rally
of course
she's talking in front of dozens of
people but the point is that they're
gonna replay this over and over and over
on steve bannon's trader tv
on everywhere they can they're gonna
repeat this garbage
because she said it
and the fascists love her
these people in this crowd cheered yeah
bicycles are the enemy
yeah
how many of these people you think went
home and trashed their kids bikes
how many
because now uh bicycles are the liberal
enemy we gotta have big trucks get your
kid a truck don't get him a bike
what the [ __ ] are you doing huh
those bicycles are for libtards
what are you talking about man
don't look away
don't look away you may get distracted
uh
thanks to all the people out there who
post these clips of these trump rallies
out here for us to see
uh some more trump rally
clips let's move past the chris rock and
will smith stuff for now
oh here minus
speaking of the crowd
may or may not have doctored this you
know what's funny about this
is of course we're partnered with modest
dutch um
[Laughter]
but they they drove stick people the the
best one is the uh is the smiley face
here right
but on instagram when they post on
instagram they actually had to market
satire
so that everyone knew that it was
so the trump supporters so the trump
supporters would know that it was
[ __ ] fake
yeah
robin says call daniel yeah and our
daniel dale
as you know as you know we have a little
bit of a spat with daniel dale here so
does midas touch and daniel dale is a
cnn fact checker
and and i i even said paige daniel dale
on this you know he's he's fact-checked
gabe a couple times
now here on the tony michael's podcast a
couple couple the uh statements that may
or may not have come from mar-a-lago
that ended up on gabe's twitter account
i don't know maybe he snuck into
mar-a-lago or something
but here we have you see the empty seats
you see the empty bleachers
um you know one of the fakest things
about donald trump really honestly is
that
he has the support that people say he
has
[Music]
okay let's see
oh oh we're going to talk about this
later on
we're doing a uh um
a special bonehead madness here's one of
the polls look who won
so we'll talk about that when gabe comes
on this is this is kind of gabe's game
um let's see oh here's here's another
here's another great clip
from the trump rally
this is uh uh herschel walker
you know him as the uh the
bonehead who got hit way too many times
in the head but is running he lives in
texas but he's running
for a senate seat in georgia you know
these [ __ ] idiots like to do this
voter fraud thing like josh holly mark
meadows and now herschel walker where
they live in one state but they run for
a seat in another by claiming they live
there which they don't you know voter
fraud
um
but listen let's listen to this this
this fraud speak about
ctr crt or cte i don't know whatever
whatever comes out of his mouth let's
listen for this country
people want to ask me all the time why
i'm running i'm sick and tired i'm sick
and tired of them want to
teach ctr in
school
critical race theory can you tell me
what that mean
i don't even know that you can tell us
what ctr means
oh [ __ ] this is this is absolute this is
batshit crazy this is batshit crazy here
here's herschel walker talking about
critical
race theory
crt by the way
number one can't even get the acronym
right and the reason why you can't get
the acronym right is because he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about crt
or what it means or education or public
education or school board meetings he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
he doesn't care
and the reason why he doesn't care
because he actually isn't running for
anything
he was just like yeah i'm a celebrity
i'll be a politician it'll be cool just
like donald trump and donald trump
convinced him yeah you'll you'll be our
token our token black guy who wins in
georgia
convinced him hook line sinker
that's right i said it
herschel walker is being duped not hard
probably
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about public
education
if he gave two [ __ ] about public
education he would at least know what
the acronym the acronym is crt not ctr
which you know we can go around and
round around about as crt and where it
is and where it didn't what it is what
it didn't i mean it's all voodoo it's
all a [ __ ] line and it's a racist
trope and here this guy can't even get
the racist trope correct because he
doesn't even give a [ __ ] about getting
it correct that's how much he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about education
doesn't give two [ __ ]
if he gave a [ __ ] he'd at least get the
acronym right
he'd at least get the acronym right even
if he gave a [ __ ] about tearing down
public education in this country because
that's what it's about
that's what it's about it's about
running running
running
only white people running the education
system in this country that's what crt
is about and the school board meetings
that is
it's only about white people running
running school boards and running
schools that's what they want
don't believe me
go look at some of your local school
board elections that are going to happen
this year
go look at them go online search them
all the candidates all the candidates
that are running and are talking about
crt almost every single one of them
white men
almost every single one of my knowing
where i'm voting almost every single one
of them are white men and they say crt
oh we're concerned about crt
of course herschel walker here should be
worried about cte probably
seemed like he had one too many blows to
the head can't he can't get the acronym
right i don't know
i i don't really think he's that stupid
i think i think he really doesn't give
two shits to know what crt is
i think is the case
that's what i think
and he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
education so that's that's that's my
take on this
[ __ ]
but again crt
is just
white people wanting to make sure that
all public education is
white people you got it
it's controlled by white folk
that's what they're trying to do um and
it do let's see oh here we go
here's another on brand
uh clip
from the trump rally i said a sex
trafficker nominating a [ __ ] grabber
for speaker
on brand for gqp
okay
let's watch the clip
i don't even have to give you much
context here because forehead our five
head here
matt gatz is speaking
you know it's gonna be a bunch of
fascist [ __ ] let's let's listen in
give us the ability to fire nancy pelosi
take back the majority
impeach joe biden and i'm going to
nominate donald trump for speaker of the
united states house of representatives
listen to what the cheeto test mobster
says here
watch the dismount here thank you very
much this is incredible
well that was interesting even he's not
impressed
even he's not impressed he's like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] this guy's off his rocker
he's off his rocker
i can't even believe that this is the
thing we have to talk about and let's
let's let's bring in um
my executive producer and co-host gabe
yeah oh
there we go can we hear you gabe
yeah i can't hear you your microphone is
not working nope
nope get out get out of here get out of
here not welcome get out of here you
can't run the microphone you're not
welcome here figure out your figure it
out come back no you got to turn it on
yeah you push the button and turn it off
can you hear that
we got kind of can we can we
kind of get now you're good oh my god he
learned how to run the microphone you
know every week we go through i check i
plugged in the computer and the in the
ports and i did the thing and then this
thing yeah and then here we are i don't
know what's going on but you can hear me
now i can hear you you're a little your
video's a little slow but i can hear you
are you good now there no there you are
no no you're there i think you're i
think you're caught up now let's go back
to the
the matt gatz clip while you're trying
to figure out your uh your latency over
there um
so this matt gats clip where he's
talking about making donald trump the
speaker of the house now a lot of people
i got a lot of comments like this bozo
doesn't he know that you have to be a
member of the house to be a speaker the
house you do not that's not a thing
there's nothing saying
there's nothing saying speaker of the
house has to be a member of congress
does not say that that's not a thing you
actually they actually can nominate
someone from outside uh congress to be
the speaker of the house yeah you
wouldn't even have a felony if i
remember if i well yeah i mean why not
why not i mean there's a lot of congress
people that have felonies you don't have
to not have felonies to be a congressman
yeah i mean you know well you know birds
birds of a feather right right right
right that's what they say
but but donald trump here could be the
speaker of the house if they take
control now he doesn't seem impressed he
doesn't seem impressed by this right
like at the end he's like oh that was
interesting
well it's also not the first time that
this has ever been like floated out
there
so it shouldn't be any surprise to him
unless of course he is having some sort
of uh
uh
early stage kind of like uh or not real
estate i don't know i guess like you
know if he's having like memory issues
we'll say
this definitely has not been the first
time that anyone has ever pitched that
as an option and i'm pretty sure he's
commented on that before
right unless it's time
well but it's not just matt gatt's
floating this this is this is there are
people running actively in their races
who aren't
currently congress people like joe
canton washington's third he's running
on this like he's like i'm gonna be
in the congress to make sure that donald
trump is the speaker so we can remove
biden and kamala and make him king like
they're saying this [ __ ] out loud right
right like it's not a secret that
they're trying to hide oh yeah no no at
this point they're just full on like
this is what we want to you know for
for a group that wants to say that you
know we're fascists and we're
controlling you know they're the ones
who are like we're gonna overthrow and
kick them out and put them in and it's
like chill dude which which one do you
want do you want the fascism that you're
talking about literally on stage right
now of overthrowing a government and
controlling what you want how you want
where you want why you want it like all
these things or do you actually want
democracy and obviously the answer is
the former not the latter because we all
know what happened at you know january
6th
before january 6 january 6 and then
after january 6 right like right
well i mean i mean so
this is obviously
uh when matt gatt says stuff like this
i'm going to transition here this is
like a slap in the face
of america
and you should not okay so now let's get
to it i i you know i can't i can't even
resist here we've got to go we got to
get gabe's opinion
on the the slap could you feel the slap
even you were out there in l.a could you
feel the slide yeah there was a i i felt
a tremble feel the whiff that was it
wasn't the whiff it was the it was the
step in and right you know like it was
that momentum right but it shook
everyone i what i will say about it is
like
okay uh it's a very
very messy right like a very very all
the whole [ __ ] thing the whole thing
is very messy right so we all watched a
person there there's a i've seen a lot
of good takes a lot of bad takes in the
last like 12 hours right um
we're gonna we're gonna be probably some
people are gonna consider our takes bad
right some people are like oh they're
spot on because in this situation well
this is what i say one
uh it does show you know and there's a
couple people that i've seen say this is
like it does show that there are two
worlds that exist right
the rich
right and the non-rich right the fact
that a rich you know man could walk on
stage assault someone live on television
and go back to his seat and watch the
rest of the show without any sort of
repercussion
says something about the way in which uh
something can be handled well i i agree
with you there but what if what if jada
was the one that went up there and
slapping don't you think there would
have been way more repercussions in that
very moment for her to go up on stage
and do yeah yeah yeah absolutely i mean
there's yeah you know no no question no
question
it's not it's not just rich it's a rich
man which is right either it's key there
now let's let's play this clip i'm going
to play the clip let's play the clip
real quick because it's a couple minutes
long
here um i'm actually going to fast
forward here
because a lot of it is kind of
irrelevant but
um but i do want to play the the joke
before
um on penelope cruz because i think this
is important let's listen to this
y'all got to see it it's really good you
know who's got the hardest job tonight
javier goddamn and his wife are both
nominated
now now he says his wife as if penelope
cruz isn't a really famous person right
yeah
he loses he can't win
he is praying now of course she she
seems mortified he's he knows it's jokes
he's laughing regardless he is he he is
clearly not going to go up on stage and
smack the [ __ ] out of chris rock and let
me tell you i bet
i bet he could lay him out
like will smith didn't really lay him
out we'll talk about that right right i
bet he could lay him out but let's let's
listen to this joke here dang that well
spent plans like please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane two can't wait
to see it so there's the joke right
there's the joke okay so
let's let's let's put our ourselves
first in the comedian's shoes right
right now chris rock is doing a job here
he's he's going up on stage to tell
jokes he is a comedian and to present an
award now i don't know for sure
no facts have been given yet rather
chris rock wrote these jokes someone
wrote these jokes for chris rock or
chris rock was was riffing here like
like don wrinkles a lot of people are
are harkening back to the don wrinkles
day when you would pay money to go get
[ __ ] insulted by don wrinkles right
right now now now i don't know who wrote
what and if they wrote or he wrote or if
he's riffing here
but this joke is off-handed right the
aim is way off just like the joke before
was the aim was way off
like this is why comedians and comedy
these days is getting such a bad rap is
because their aim
is wrong for 2022 right right you have
aim with comedy and you can aim it in a
certain direction but you are the you
you make jokes all the time so tell us
what did you think about these two jokes
uh in particular the one before and then
the one that caused this event right all
right so i i you know i look at the two
and i'm you know i
considering the context in the situation
obviously the latter of the two jokes
here is where it gets real kind of
touchy
you know the the former of the two the
first one uh versus you know penelope
cruz javier bardem you know it's
you know ever you know it's not so bad
but obviously you know it does you know
it's commentary on a relationship right
because here's the thing
uh
there is
actual um
uh history
behind
you know accomplishments and
relationship status between the couples
who are both in the industry you know
you look at people um halle berry is an
example right uh i don't know if her
husband's in the industry but you know
she won an oscar and there's actually um
there there are there are some articles
about like how relationships can
uh can fall apart based on you know and
this is this is also true of other
industries too but you know the the
film industry was an example of how
accomplishments for people in the
industry obviously can be look
it can take a take apart a relationship
where it's like one person is more
successful and especially if the woman
in the relationship or the wife in the
relationship is more successful than the
man or the husband you know that you
know whether it's a dig at the ego or
you know the macho
feeling of being a man or whatever it is
it definitely has an effect now i'm not
saying that's
that justifies it i'm just saying like
that is something that exists right now
and again is true of
any relationship in any industry right
especially if you're in the same
industry and you are technically
competing in your success especially you
know if you feel invalidated or insecure
or whatever that's obviously on the guy
for that but
uh again not trying to justify it so i
think the joke here like
there is a little bit of that rooted
there
it's whatever i didn't think it was as
harmful now when you move over
to the next joke right now obviously the
first joke right it's talking about like
oh like oh it's misogynistic right
exactly it's gonna say like a woman is
emotional and she's you know if she
doesn't get what she wants whatever and
that's not good now i'm i'm not i'm not
saying that's a good joke but what i am
saying is when you move over from that
joke and then you compare it to the next
joke which is talking about you know
jada pinkett's uh
uh alopecia right so whether he knew
about it or didn't know about it because
that is the question right right rather
chris rock actually knew
about uh her alopecia now and she came
out recently in 2021 about it you know
right so the story is because i i didn't
i actually didn't know this um i'm not
uh a staunch follower of will smith or
jada pinkett smith uh to be quite honest
with you i don't i mean i think i might
follow a couple of their accounts but
i'm not like always looking at what
they're doing um so i i didn't see and i
guess it was instagram where she um
revealed her alopecia is that correct it
might it might have well she's got the
red table talk that's like on facebook
so but but but somewhere somewhere
somewhere she revealed yeah on social
media to millions of people right and
and before that she'd been wearing wigs
and this sort of thing now rather chris
rock knew that or not it is it is
unknown at this point a lot of people in
the room know it and here's why because
you're going to see the reaction in the
room when he says this because i think a
lot of people in the room knew it some
people knew it some people did not if
you watch the reaction here because this
is the moment right after the joke
now you see here
here's the reaction from the people he's
aiming at jada peak and smith
you're going to see her roll her eyes
and she's very visibly upset yeah will
smith here
at this point now rather he heard the
joke or he realized what he said i don't
know right but he's laughing he's
visibly laughing and the people i think
within the within the next 10 seconds or
or or less
i think there are a lot of variables
that come into play
he either doesn't realize the joke and
he's kind of laughing with it
i think we lost him
i think we lost you
yeah we lost gabe now
okay let's let's play it here because
i'm gonna tell you what's gonna happen
here
as we try to get gabe back
so here jade is very very very upset
very upset
um you can see her cringing will smith
is still laughing now now it cuts back
to chris rock um i think this is you
know a lot of people are you know
creating controversy over this because
you can't see
what
jaden will say to each other or any kind
of video
between them right
let's um
we'll wait for gabe to come back and
we'll talk about this a little more but
we don't see the interaction between
will smith and jada peak and smith at
least on this view this view apparently
is from
some other live feed other than the
united states and the reason why is
because in the united states they
actually censored some of the stuff that
was said once the slap happened this
wasn't censored but part of the slap was
so let's continue to watch here until we
get to the moment of the slap
that's jealous that was a nice one okay
so obviously the room did not see
the room did not see it as something
that was tasteful
some laughed some did not and it's i
think it's obvious that some were
laughing because they did not know about
the alopecia thing or they didn't give a
[ __ ]
or and there were people who knew that
it was cringe-worthy because of her
revelation that she had made publicly
about her disease that she has the
alopecia where she
cuts her hair very very short because
she has alopecia and she's been wearing
wigs and she decided like gabe said i
think we got gabe back here are you back
now yeah yeah i'm back i'm back oh and
you're better see you're your audio's on
no latest
yeah you should have done that earlier
okay what i will say is um within that
like with you know like less than 10
second moments
will smith went from laughing whether he
realized the joke or not was leighton in
his own right to hear the joke and
realize what he said
uh turned over and so i was like oh
jadis pissed [ __ ] right okay because it
went from laugh to walk up slap
within a flash right right right well
here here it is let's let's go back and
look at the
i mean here here is the joke
here is uh them and i'm not going to
play it i'm just going to show you she's
rolling her eyes pretty heavy here
will's laughing now that cuts away from
them and i haven't been able to find
uh you i don't think you will be able to
i don't think you'll find a piece of
footage that well i mean it exists
somewhere but not anywhere that is
public right you're not going to find
that piece of footage probably uh of
what the what the interaction was
between will and jada
after
he says this joke right
but almost immediately you know chris
rock again the room's reaction
i think is obvious that a lot of people
knew about the alopecia some people did
not know right and the people who didn't
know thought it was really cringe-worthy
because chris rock's like uh it landed
he could tell it ran it landed wrong
yeah yeah and it's also i mean like he
had to be like oh well it wasn't so bad
right like whether that was a riff and
it was adam it was just like an ad-lib
kind of joke there or it was planned i
don't know i mean you know based on how
he kind of responded afterward but on
top of that it's like once you see will
smith come back and he's get my wife's
name out your [ __ ] mouth right you
people
people aren't like here's the thing
immediately after this happened everyone
was like is this a bit
no right right well here's here's the
thing
because kathy griffin made a really good
point she said
um by will smith doing this
he is actually putting in danger a lot
of comedians for the will smith viral
moment now in a comedy club because
here's the thing
will smith is a jackass for doing this
will smith is not an audience member
right he's not someone who paid money to
come to the oscars to watch this event
will smith is a [ __ ] professional
performer just like chris rock and there
are some times where your performance
whether you like it or not lands wrong
and it it and sometimes you make a
mistake as a performer you can do that
especially a comedian when you're making
jokes chris rocks obviously made
a wrong decision here whoever had this
joke in the teleprompter for him uh this
joke was offhanded it was probably a
mistake but he doesn't even get a chance
basically to apologize for it because
will smith steps all over that right
because i like this the way that it is
is like the it was a cheap it was a poor
a cheap joke in poor taste right exactly
and will smith coming up there to uh you
know he he could have taken that moment
and been like hey
and like addressed alopecia right yeah
he could have gotten from the microphone
yeah he could have gotten from the
microphone and schooled chris rock make
chris locke look like a total [ __ ]
jackass right and he and he would have
looked like he would have been
protecting or defending as he said in
his acceptance speech his family and his
wife's disease but instead
he went up there and chose violence
which is like again you know every
i obviously violence is not the first
option people joke about it you know
like rand paul's neighbor and all that
stuff but like right in this moment you
know there are
people who are who were triggered by the
trauma who are survivors
of of
of violence and obviously that wasn't a
great thing to see on national
television uh in front of millions right
whether you're young or you're older
and again it was a cheap joke that was
made in poor taste and it was will smith
going up there to decide that this
physical altercation assault was the
right choice going forward to establish
himself as the protector now
uh both of these two are in the wrong
for both things that they did right well
here's the thing here's the thing is it
takes away
it takes away all conversation by what
will smith did what chris rock and will
smith did here this interaction between
these two not just the joke not just the
slap not just the yelling back and forth
but it totally [ __ ] takes away all
discussion the a real discussion that
you can have about people with alopecia
right and now it's totally
the collateral damage of the situation
because of the joke and also the assault
so it's like now it looks even worse and
yes again like i was saying he could
have gone up there and he could have
said his two cents and said hey alopecia
is a real thing and it affects millions
especially women and the in the double
down on that is like it's not only women
but women from uh from the black
community also like here's a big thing
chris rock even made uh i remember
seeing the documentary in 2000 yeah good
hair
yes good hair which is about his
daughter and trying to conform to hair
expectations from you know uh you know
uh stripping your hair of your of your
natural of looks to make it more white
you know there's a whole thing so like
he
but here's but here's the thing also
about comedy is sometimes comedy is not
necessarily your personal opinion and
and even if you make an offhanded joke
it doesn't mean you actually believe it
like a comedian a comedian is a using
exaggeration it doesn't mean they
actually believe the exaggeration um but
again we don't know if chris rock and
again i'm not i'm not justifying the
joke the joke was horrible right we
don't know if he wrote it if someone
wrote it for him if he made it
off-handed and we'll probably never know
that we'll probably never know that
we're just going to assume that chris
rock had this in his brain and he said
this shitty joke right but here's the
thing it doesn't mean he actually
believes it it's because he's a comedian
so so there's a lot of context here but
i i do want to say that chris rock
actually gives will smith an out even
after the slap gives him an out because
in true form of chris rock knowing
because i think that's the biggest
difference here chris rock was being a
comedian will smith was not being
anything but a piece of [ __ ] here right
and what i mean by that is he saw red
and he was gonna go punch someone um
which is it which is a really bad
decision i think it actually cost him
two or three years of his career here uh
i i believe that i i believe he's gonna
have to mel gibson this thing where he's
gonna have to bury himself you know
which is unfortunate because here's the
thing
when have you ever met someone who said
i don't like will smith right like will
smith has been able to oh you will now
well yeah no no i don't that's what i'm
saying but like how quickly you know and
even said in a speech i'm not saying
that speech
made up for what he did but you know
he's he mentioned denzel washington he's
like even at your highest moment the
devil will come for you right and like
in this moment when you're at your high
like your [ __ ] peak he's winning an
oscar this is the this is the pinnacle
of your career like this is what you
always want to achieve right you want to
go for the oscar
to uh
to all the all the accolades to say that
i am a great actor in this industry and
i am better than all these other people
you know
but
it's it's that moment right like how
quickly you can go from on the top to
bottom and you know people were laughing
and clapping in his acceptance speech
but it's right back on top i mean 20
minutes later this guy wins an oscar
right
it's cr the time i mean it was i will
say this like
uh i can't remember the last time i
watched an oscars like oh this is crazy
right like i i don't even know crazy
that's [ __ ] crazy
and
and uh
this is one of those times where it's
like yeah again there are two classes of
people the rich and the famous versus
none like if this were to happen
anywhere else and you made a point i
know i cut out at this point but like
with kathy griffin she had a tweet and i
i've talked to several other comedians
myself last night were like
what the [ __ ] did will do like why would
he do that over a joke like he was doing
his job as comedian whether the jokes
were good or not like that yeah okay
well i mean they totally jaida and will
could have totally came up to to chris
rock afterwards and said hey
that was a really shitty joke explain to
him why it was a shitty joke if chris
rock didn't understand chris rock could
have said now i understand he could have
made an apology they could have they
could have made a damn viral video about
alopecia and creating now here's this
now here's the flip side though in that
moment of assault right the not
not saying it was good or anything i'm
saying that in this moment right this
viral moment that got a ton of eyes on
it
there is a co i'm not saying it
justified it but there now is a
conversation that's happening around
jokes specifically also jokes uh
targeted against women right and women
who suffer from alopecia uh there's a
conversation about hair happening now
there's a whole thing so i'm not saying
that it's justifying what happened but
now as a result there is a conversation
right now it's heated
it is definitely heated in like uh well
because now everyone knows i mean if you
didn't know before the jada beacon smith
had alopecia you know now right and you
know why it was a shitty joke let's
watch the moment that it happens here
because i gotta i got a lot of thoughts
on the actual slappier that was that was
a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
wow
wow
will smith just smacked the [ __ ] out of
me
okay so at this point i will give chris
props the fact that he was able to
continue
he like before the follow through was
done he was telling a joke right like he
was telling a joke now this is the
moment that i i've been saying this is
chris rock giving will smith an out
because the entire room thought this was
staged like they're laughing they think
this is part of the gag
the room thinks at this point that this
could be part of the gag they're
laughing ha ha will smith just smacked
the [ __ ] out of chris rock
and chris rock is giving him an out here
by smiling telling him a joke will smith
goes and sits down and does that
i think i think if he doesn't do what he
does in this moment afterwards
they could have said
who knows if it was staged who knows who
knows it could have been it could have
been the the moment that no one knows if
it was staged or not uh in in oscar
history but will smith really shits all
over that here um
you know where chris rock gives him the
comedian
who was assaulted on stage by by chris
rock for the shitty joke that he just
told regardless of rather chris rock
knows it which i think chris rock at
this point knows it was shitty because
of the reaction of the room most
comedians would understand right
especially because he was like oh come
on it wasn't so bad right it was that mo
when he had to come out as as chris rock
and then say and respond as opposed to
you know whatever but like you know he
had to respond
to the reaction of the room right of the
room i was like because it was like some
people some people thought it was funny
some people knew they're like uh that's
a touchy topic for several reasons don't
do that and then obviously it it
developed into uh an assault that we all
witnessed
but it is something that you look at it
and you're like
this would like this is something that
you would not
you know get away with you know now
you've got this moment where you know
lapd is involved they're saying they're
not going to investigate you know
they're not going to i mean yeah chris
rock chris rock is not going to press
charges and here here's here's what i'll
tell you is that this event could have
been much worse
yeah and and and um
will smith committing violence on
grizzrack is unacceptable right but the
fact that chris rock did not because i
mean i'll tell you it would have been
very difficult for me
to stand there and let someone swing at
me without to defend myself i mean
physically to not not with a joke not
with you know trying to laugh it off i'm
talking about physically defending
myself especially knowing that it wasn't
staged it would have been very difficult
for someone
i think someone not to defend themselves
um now i i think chris rock
did it you know his joke was shitty
but his dismount here
with uh the slap
um
was as a comedian
as we see the next exchange this is
where
you watch chris rocco
moving on like there's a moment where he
goes like well here just play it and yep
wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane joke
and that's the moment when the room knew
it was not staged yeah like that's the
moment and and really people here in in
america thought that this was all staged
because they didn't get to hear this
they just saw this because
right right the audio so you couldn't
hear the reaction in the room you
couldn't hear what they were saying to
each other so a lot of people thought
this was staged but this is the moment
you know this is not staged
[Applause]
i'm going to okay
and that is that the moment you're
talking about or is it the one after
this nope it comes after
oh
okay right there
he was like oh i could i can right right
but because because what he wanted to do
is chris rock wanted to lay into
will smith about all kinds of issues
with him and his wife right and he
didn't yeah and he didn't the reason why
is because he knew what would happen
possibly if he did so as a professional
comedian chris rock is actually looking
over to get a signal from the crew i
think here to say are we moving on are
we going to a break what is going to
happen here because chris rock is is uh
is trying to decide professionally what
he's doing as a right he's like do i he
i i think it was that moment where there
were a couple things that were happening
one
i think he was also like ooh you [ __ ]
up legally
uh and also
he's like i could i could [ __ ] dig up
all this [ __ ] right now and if we do
then it's gonna become a messy it's no
longer a joke right right no longer joke
these are visceral attacks against you
and your wife and the relationship and
that's what that becomes which is now
it's like oh we've moved away from jokes
and now we're going to attacks
and
that right there would be a obviously a
poor move on his part and will's part
and also would then justify a lot of
other people online to do some say some
very racist things even though we've
already seen it in the last 12 hours
where people are now justifying
how
to treat
people who are minorities black people
you know communities whatever have you
uh because of this they're saying like
oh well
um here's violence this is why this
person is whatever and then like because
i've seen a ton of racist stuff in the
last 12 hours of people who are
justifying the assault and saying that's
why they are blank that's why he's blank
that's why that like it's a it's a it's
really it's gross and disgusting and
people are using as an opportunity to
say boom especially as we're on the
heels
of
the uh supreme court uh uh
um nomination hearing right
jackson and we had all the races
a whole week of these white dudes
talking to a black woman about how
she wasn't you know she seemed nice but
uh she was you know uh coming after us
right you heard trump at the rally who's
like she was disrespectful like all that
[ __ ] and then it's like she had the
poise and composure and
uh and strength to sit there and take it
you know be formal and and try to
correct when she could
and then
you have this flip side of like within
48 hours or 72 hours of the last time
she was uh answering questions you have
another person from the black community
who who assaults another person from the
black community thus making other people
say oh well
this way you can't do whatever that's
why you can't say whatever that's why
you can't trust whatever and it's a very
very slippery slope and i see a lot of
people who are trying to who are either
conflating things
or trying to justify their own racism
uh which is disgusting and vile to see
and i and again like the one thing i was
trying to say earlier is
i spoke to comedians last night like
fellow comedians here in la
and they also have one where they're
very concerned about
this the precedent that has just been
set right now not everyone is going to
be able to go up there on stage and be
like i don't like the [ __ ] joke that
you made against right whatever and they
take action now it's like okay this
person is definitely gonna that that
there is no way this person doesn't get
in trouble hopefully
but it also now sets the bar to say if
you don't like the joke that has been
made against you or a group of people
you can now assault and take a
force against the person on stage who
has taken the jokes not saying that the
jokes are justified or good or whatever
they could be shitty jokes however now
there is a precedent set that if you
don't like the joke you could go up
there and assault the the comedian who's
delivering the joke so it's it's all
messy it's all really messy right there
and it's not just the the the fact
between will smith and chris rock
because um we've seen uh the report from
lapd that chris rock is not going to
file charges um which which means that
will smith is it doesn't seem to be
legally held accountable for this we
also see that um you know people are
calling for his oscar to be stripped
from him uh the academy he says they're
considering it which then then you get
into this another race discussion
because harvey weinstein and mel gibson
who have committed violence granted not
on stage but it doesn't matter it's
violence as violence is violence right
um
you know
again
this is all really messy and it's all a
big discussion
but guess what guess what it is a
discussion that we get to have in this
country
because we have a democracy
and because because we get to have
things like the oscars because i make
the case
that if we if we do not if we do not
protect our democracy we do not have we
do not get to have moments of the oscars
where we were we socially
um and and in pop culture get to have
discussions like this where
a black man like will smith who wins an
oscar 20 minutes before goes on stage
and and slaps and physically violently
assaults a comedian who is a black man
making fun of a black woman with an
offhanded joke uh at the oscars it's
probably not a thing that would happen
um you know none of that would happen so
i know that sounds crazy
and it's all a mixture of stuff
but it's our mixture it's our pop
culture
so and i i think i think the other thing
too that this crazy [ __ ] where you're
gonna accuse someone of being certain
way because you have a certain opinion
about this because i believe you can
think that the joke of chris rock was
really [ __ ] stupid and shitty and you
can think that the the violent reaction
of will smith had was really stupid and
shitty you can also believe that if the
academy doesn't doesn't actually do
something here they're really [ __ ]
shitty right i mean you could believe
all kinds of things at once you don't
have to be on a side here
other than the side of
jada who was the [ __ ] butt of the
whole thing like not just not just the
butt of of cr because it's not like
chris rock physically assaulted her i
mean if chris rock would have physically
assaulted jada i i think that it is 100
percent uh likely that people would be
defending will uh
in a way that is probably legitimate to
defend his wife violently and physically
you know when it's self-defense but not
over a joke
not over a joke and again she's the one
that is at the expense of all of this
all of it and for anyone to attack her
is a piece of [ __ ] right i've seen i've
seen some people that literally said um
you're like [ __ ] will smith and his ugly
wife and it's like whoa like
again
what does that have to do like she is
the unfortunate collateral damage in the
situation she is the victim you cannot
tell me
one she's not ugly she's [ __ ]
beautiful right and and it's jada pink
and smith for crying the [ __ ] out loud
the fact that the fact that somebody
would attack it's it's moments like that
where i'm like oh cool so your your
racism is definitely showing out because
you don't agree with the assault total
okay totally fine not an issue i got it
however you do not go and attack the
woman in the situation who was
who is the bystander right you're not
only making the now you're making the
victim even worse right right like that
doesn't you you don't get to justify
your racism because of the assault right
you don't get to justify your racism by
saying she's ugly you don't get to do
any of that [ __ ] you you don't you
know like you don't deserve the ability
like you could say your stupid opinion
right your dumb ass racist opinion but
it's not right and it's not it's not uh
like it doesn't mean anything because at
the end of the day like
you're just a bigot right right well and
and i think i think again she she she
loses in the whole thing uh not just
with the chris rock joke but with will
smith actually committing violence
thinking that that was okay she's the
loser in all of this
um and and i think that that should be
shined through if anything is that she
was
you know the victim here as it were
so um speaking of and i don't mean to
transition again but speaking of
smackdowns
um we have a great new game that we are
playing here at the tony michaels
podcast that gabe has come up
what in the world what
i put
oh you're putting oh i see what you're
doing you're putting
there
it
go okay you put it in i i've got it up i
put up the new version oh okay okay
go go ahead and put up the new version
all
right
there we go yeah
[Music]
no oh can we not see that no i won't
it won't do
at it well anyway you could see us off
to the side here yeah well here here
we'll do this we'll do this this is this
is the um
this is the bonehead mat so explain
bonehead madness to everyone okay who
hasn't shown you who may want to play i
just like the fact that you can still
see us in the background yeah like oh
yeah you know you know uh well so
bonehead madness
okay go ahead so bonehead madness so
this whole idea uh right when tony and i
were talking about uh joining forces
i think this is funnier when tony never
talked about joining forces about uh the
show
you know i was like oh we should do like
something on the weekends right and so i
was like we're talking about ideas and i
was like oh you know we should call out
all these boneheads by the way i know
this is great we should call it these
boneheads and uh so that's where you see
bonehead of the week that's where that
that's where that came from and then i
said hey we got march madness we can't
call march madness it's not called march
madness
well we can't say that because we would
get a cease and desist letters right
right right right yeah if anything it
would just like kind of just or it would
validate uh what we're doing so then
what happens is i was like all right i
want to do this march madness bracket i
want to do this march madness bracket
where we um
uh no no not a march madness right right
yeah well i want to do leica like
similar but not not a march madness
bracket okay pause there pause there
because i want to let everyone know
who's listening to the podcast right now
you got to go over to the youtube
channel and watch this i am having to
con contort myself in a stupid position
just so just so um it appears that we
are on screen because gabe's graphic
work here you know his microphone works
go go ahead go ahead by the way yeah
yeah so so i said hey you should make a
march madness like bracket for boneheads
but we can't call it march madness right
right all right yeah so we'll call it
bonehead madness and that's the 2022
bonehead madness championship so you
know i could have started with like the
64 teams but that would have been a lot
of polls and i don't know if really a
lot of people would have done that take
this off the screen take this okay all
right
so all right what i did was i took 16
boneheads right we got marjorie taylor
green
we've got uh let's see i'll just pull it
up on on my own screen and i'll run it
off yeah sure um
well i mean here here we can we can put
the the here's the outdated one right so
this is the one as of yesterday morning
right we don't have all the winners
losers right uh so you had ted cruz
against josh hawley ted cruz won you had
marsha blackburn lindsey graham lindsey
graham won tucker carlson versus sean
hannity tucker carlson won candace owens
versus charlie kirk
candace owens one uh martial
charlie kirk's out of the running oh my
charlie crooks out of the running it
yeah so it's uh tucker carlson versus
candace owens ted cruz versus uh lindsey
graham marjorie taylor green beat out uh
lauren beaubert
and matt gates beat out uh madison
cawthorn ron desantis beat out uh greg
abbott and don trump jr beat out mike
lindell so the final eight or rather
sorry not the final the hateful eight as
i call them is ted cruz versus lindsey
graham for the u.s senators region you
have tucker carlson versus candace owens
in the lame stream media region you've
got uh marjorie taylor green versus matt
gates lovely couple
in the u.s representatives region and
you've got ron desantis versus don jr in
the [ __ ] waffles region
which is which was a tony name we were
trying to thanks to me thank you yeah i
was just like i got this last category
and i don't know what to name them
there's like these other people i don't
know what to call them and he and then
we went through a few and tony was like
12 waffles and i was like sounds good to
me well they are all [ __ ] waffles ron
this is great donald trump jr
they're all all 16 are [ __ ] waffles well
right right but this group of four are
12 waffles for sure right right um so
yeah so uh
now we're down to eight ted cruz lindsey
graham tucker carlson candace owens
marger taylor green matt gates grand
desantis and donald trump jr so tell
everyone how to play here because it's
interesting how you're putting this on
the twitter page because
if everyone doesn't know gabe is
actually it's not me tweeting on the
twitter page like this i had no idea
tony tony gave me full access and
he has the passport now if you do see
some some stray tweets there on the
podcast account it probably is not me
well it probably is me yeah the good
ones are probably you so the way that
it's done is i'll i'll shoot out another
one that gives an update based on the
final uh or the the hateful eight that i
just updated everyone right now with and
we'll say okay now that we're down you
know eight have been eliminated eight
remain
you decide you know what happens and um
the way that it's done is through
facebook polls so it would be you know
ted cruz this is josh hawley and then
the winner roles or
twitter polls twitter polls yeah yeah so
if you're on facebook you gotta go
follow
us over on twitter to to take the poll
at tony michael's pod that's where
they're all at and you just go to the
top right to the uh the thread
now let's come to the top and the thread
that's been at the top will have all the
current poles the games as it were yeah
yeah because these people aren't
actually battling like you know well you
know unfortunately in a way you know i
would love to sanction these people to
kind of you know go ahead i i would i
think right right
people were
kind of upset at the way that these were
stacked in a way you know uh mj thank
you okay she says uh tucker carlson's
gonna win this bad boy there you go mj's
mj's putting her prediction in with a
super chat she's even putting her
prediction in that that
[ __ ] carlson wins it all so thank you
thank you but yeah people people were
kind of vocal online uh the first couple
of rounds where people were like oh you
stacked margaret taylor green against
lauren bobert you know you stacked this
person against this person and i'm like
yeah i did because i thought that they
were contenders but they're all really
[ __ ] boneheaded i mean even marjorie
taylor green versus matt gatch you'd be
like oh where are you right exactly like
oh look at this you know i could not
have predicted that matt gates would be
against margie taylor green which is
even better because now that's the
america first situation right there
right right exactly the america first
couple is going at it right for who's
gonna go who's gonna move on to the
department right the deplorable the semi
finals and the bonehead championship
right this is important stuff here folks
it's like i i could not have set it up
this way i just put the names in
everyone on the internet that voted they
decided so you know that's all i'm
saying and if you want to say you should
share it out and get that vote skew in
another way if you feel like that so
here's the thing here's the thing is on
those first rounds they really were
weighted right like
they were waiting the ones that they
were really complaining about right they
were wait like it was clear who was the
winner like what what you weren't that
upset because there's a clear winner and
then the ones that they weren't upset
about it
it was really close it was a really
close race right they were really close
you know they kind of yeah they kind of
broke out at the end but they were close
for sure
um you know i
uh
i have no idea who's gonna win now what
tony and i did talk about and i'll have
to to compose the tweet is you know now
that we know we've done the work for you
or rather we've told you who the eight
are gone and the eight that remain
so now from here
uh
i would like people once i put out the
new bracket i would like people to fill
out their own bracket again we've
already done eight people we've already
done the first round for you
jump into the second round and we were
discussing that the winner if you can
successfully predict a bracket you got a
comment with your own bracket filled out
in the comments for this next post i'll
make on on the twitter account
and we'll give you
uh a coupon to to get a gift a merch a
gift card yeah ready you want a [ __ ]
hat or yeah or a fashion shirt or
something sure you know whatever you
want over at the the tony michaels uh
the merch store so we'll give you a gift
card you can go over there and get you
something so on the next one
yeah and the next on the next post uh
you predict from the f from the the
hateful eight down to deplorable four
down to the semifinals down to the
winner and the person who is closest
will win themselves
so there is a winner here yeah there is
a winner i mean not only a bonehead
champion but there's a winner in the
audience if you get the bracket as you
know give you a shout out say what's up
now i'm gonna i'm gonna let gabe call
the shots on this bracket whether it's
the the good or the bad or the
indifferent i'll just i'll just give
i'll just give the gift card away to the
merch store i'm i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna weigh in on these
on who wins so i'll like gabe decide
maybe and maybe we'll have to draw
straws too if the three or four people
get close and do it like a like a like a
drawing or something because um
you know who do you i i don't know i i i
want to give i don't want to give away
the prediction why i want to predict
well i mean well i don't want to give
away my final okay i don't want to go
round by round you can give the final
prediction and then people can figure
out how you get that from there okay so
so i here's my here's my semi-final can
i do that wow wow
i don't i mean oh well
no don't do that you got to say who the
winner oh my god because here's the
thing then people are going to
you know like oh i got the semi-final
like i don't know i i just want to make
sure that everyone has a coach you know
what you don't you don't you don't want
to you don't want to uh the [ __ ] in your
in the cereal as it were yeah sure yeah
if that's what you want to call it i
just want people
you could say who you think will win you
could say who you think will win but you
cannot i want you know i i want to do
what everyone always does i want all of
them to win all the above
i mean they're all they're all bonehead
champions
but we got to determine
who the bonehead is yeah well it is it
happens it happens i i don't know i
think after the comments um uh this
weekend at the trump rally um to me
marjorie taylor green that piece of [ __ ]
um she receives bonehead champion in my
mind every single day um for for the
comments that she made and how she's
trying to draw
um lines in between
the lgbt community and
um old ass tropes that happen um we had
we had uh brad bad brad berkwith um and
i was thinking about this as she was
[ __ ] saying this [ __ ]
on stage we had bad brad berkwith
on our show and you guys should go watch
that interview it's a great interview
because we talk about his dad alan
berkwith in 1977
when anita bryant was
was on her anti-gay crusade down in
miami when they were trying to prevent
well they what they were trying to do is
ostracize gay people from society and
and florida has come full circle again
back to that um
but his dad alvin stood on the street
and defended
um
gay people in miami and their right to
be employed
the right to be employed and to be human
beings
and that that video is on
is on
that interview and it's a fantastic
fantastic display of what americans
should how they should view humanity and
and the exact opposite happened on stage
with marjorie taylor green she is a
despicable vile vile person um she is a
human being but in my eyes in my eyes
um
this is we do not have to tolerate the
intolerant and that is absolutely
intolerant um so in my mind
me
i would love
i would love for every single day for
her foot green to win bonehead champion
she is the bonehead champ in my mind so
whether she wins this bracket or not
that's my feeling on all these of course
of course you know they're they're not
they're all these are right up in behind
her like tucker carlson charlie kirk
candace i mean you name them they're
right up behind marjorie taylor green in
my book yeah i mean
i could not have predicted who
who would make it through the next
rounds or who will make it down and
because that's your vote it's their vote
right right because also
these boneheads every single day they
are doing something brand new and fresh
that will
you're like oh boom they're up by two oh
they're down by seven right right
someone's got it
now you got you got someone who's hot
who's hot on the board so go to the at
tony michael's tonymichaelspod at
tonymichaelspot on twitter now we'll
keep pinning it to the top of the page
you can go vote uh who you want to win
those games and that's how we come up
with a winner for each single and every
round of this bone ed madness to make
sure to see who is in the semi-finals or
who's in the the hateful eight as you
call it right are the late the hate
sinister sinister 16 hatefully wait
deplorable four deplorable four in the
semifinals down to
who the bonehead champ will be we will
crown the champ this of course we'll
know who the champ is but we will crown
the champ this friday remember every
single friday in the second hour we have
bonehead of the week we will still do a
bone end of the week bowl but we will
not only go through the bone end of the
week poll
we will go through who the bone ed
champion was will be this week for the
bracket
so stay tuned to that again go over to
the twitter page
uh
like and you know follow there but also
vote for
who you want to be
in the hateful eight
um today today's there's two polls
there will be uh two polls today and
we'll do two polls tomorrow i mean let's
let's think this out right so if there's
two problems today and two polls
tomorrow that's that's tuesday right and
then there that brings us to deplorable
four deplorable four so that would be so
wednesday thursday and friday so what i
could do is i could do two today two
tomorrow
yeah just just do it however it works so
that we know
we know sometime thursday night friday
morning
who this winner is so that way we can
announce it and give everyone i'll do it
i'll do it two today two tomorrow
and then the last
two games
i'll do on uh on on thursday good and or
wednesday and then uh thursday we have
ourselves the semi-finals so by friday
we announce who the winner is now i said
i said um
earlier on in the week
uh or or the weekend excuse me when this
bracket came out i said
i said you know what we could actually
run this bracket probably next year um
depending on indictments depending on
indictments we could probably depend on
who's who's still
at large we'll say
right right i mean but i i also i also
said speaking of at large because it
rhymes with marge uh i said
that if
marge if marjorie taylor grain wins the
whole thing i will rename it to uh well
at least for this year i will rename it
to marge madness marge madness let's see
that's really close because that we
might get a cease and desist from
somebody because i'm just because i
could say marge madness marge madness
this is not march madness for cbs this
is not what this is this is bone ed
madness right it could turn into marge
marge madness
man yeah merge man yeah i guess it's all
based on the region you're in you know
well i could be it could be well
gabe thanks for all the hard work on
this bonehead madness um poll it's very
important here that we make sure that
everyone um
gets a chance to vote on the games are
you sticking with us we're going to go
to a break real quick are you thinking
you got time to stick with us or
[Music]
everyone check out the poll at tony
michael's pod yeah by the time you come
back the new poll
will be up okay okay great great great
we'll go check it out when we come back
everyone stick with us we'll be right
back after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
years
bomb
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
[Music]
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
thanks for joining us every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific right
here on youtube twitter twitch and now
now on the midas touch facebook page
thanks for all the new listeners out
there we really appreciate it again
don't forget to go over to the tony
michael's pod
uh at tonymichaelspod the twitter page
to go vote uh in the games of bonehead
madness this week
again um gabe's gonna be putting up a
tweet uh later on today
about
um
about who can win the the uh
the the gift certificate to the merch
store whether you want a [ __ ] hat or
a fascism suck shirt or a a thanks
brandon mug just just
so be paying attention we'll put those
in in the threads so that you know how
you can
um do that so so fill out your
fill out your bracket
in the comment section
to win a merch store gift card
we'll put the details on
on
at tony michael's pod twitter page so go
check it out there go follow over there
and vote
vote vote vote for who wins
bonehead champion the champion the champ
uh let's go see if he has the um
see if he has the poll up here the new
one the new one
is he behind and he's still behind well
we'll get it up there we'll get up there
we're 41 minutes into the second hour
again we have two hours let's go to the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
really quick like um
because there are there's some more news
um that is out there besides will smith
and
chris rock that is affecting our world
uh john eastman
um
there's a few contempt charges it looks
like breaking a judge orders john
eastman to release his emails he
attempted to withhold from the january
6th select committee uh trump's plan had
worked it would have permanently ended
the peaceful transfer of power
undermining american democracy so it
looks like kyle is reporting here
that john eastman
is going to be ordered to release his
emails
that involve the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup we also seen over the weekend that
was buried in the will smith chris rock
news
that there were a few contempt charges
from peter navarro and dan scavino jr
that were issued it looks like the
january 6 select committee may hold them
in contempt
let's see
let's either hugo has a breaking federal
judge orders trump lawyer john eastman
to release emails to january 6 select
committee saying the court finds more
likely than not trump and eastman
dishonestly conspire to obstruct the
joint session of congress
which is uh possibly a
conspiracy of sedition ah don't you
think hmm
sounds familiar oath keepers and proud
boys uh maybe even has something to do
with roger stone wouldn't you think
um i believe we're getting closer and
closer aaron says here uh wow read this
line from the ruling today ordering that
john eastman releases emails to the
january 6 committee
the court finds that more than likely
that not that
then excuse me the court finds it more
likely than not that president trump
corruptly attempted
corruptly attempted to instruct the
joint session of congress on january 6
2021
is the quote from the court filing aaron
reports here now this is this is very
significant and the reason why it's
significant is the judge is not just
talking about john eastman
this is a conspiracy we've seen this
word before in these federal indictments
in these federal indictments we have
seen this word before conspiracy to
commit sedition
we have 11 oath keepers um several proud
boys that are charged with seditious
conspiracy we've seen that these um oath
keepers and the proud boys met in a
parking garage enrique tario and stewart
rhodes the founder of the oath keepers
and and the leader of the proud boys at
the time
we're meeting in a parking garage
to conspire with sedition
um where we seen
one of those proud boys who has pled
guilty to seditious conspiracy
who the day of january 6
that the judge is saying that there was
a corrupt attempt to obstruct the joint
session of congress
to certify the results
one of those oath keepers joshua james
has pled guilty in the federal court
the thing funny thing about joshua james
if you didn't know which i'm sure you do
is he was he was uh
tasked
with the personal protection of roger
stone
that day on january 6th
roger stone as you know is the personal
friend and confidant
of
and uh a
pardon
recipient
of donald j trump the president at the
time on january 6 who called
to action the insurrection
and you had the proud boys and the oath
keepers on standby so much so that they
were defending his personal confidence
who may or may not have been in personal
contact with the president united states
we seen we seen that jeannie thomas was
in contact with the chief of staff mark
meadows why in the [ __ ] is it so hard to
believe that roger stone would have had
a direct line to the president of the
united states
why is that so hard to believe
i don't think it's that hard to believe
i don't actually don't think it's far
stretch
that roger stone and donald trump were
communicating that day
or the day before the day after during
the insurrection even
while he was receiving roger stone that
is protection
from one of the oath keepers who's pled
guilty and seditious conspiracy which it
seems like john eastman
and donald trump
are now being accused in a federal court
of some sort of seditious conspiracy
the court finds that it is more likely
than not
based on the evidence of the emails this
is not like the court's guessing
the court saw the emails and the saying
the court finds it more than likely than
not
that the president of the united states
at the time the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants the orange mussolini
jesus himself
corruptly attempted to obstruct the
joint session of congress they stopped
short of saying he's part of the
seditious conspiracy i'm guessing
they're leaving it up the prosecutors at
the doj
hmm
so bring on bring on more of the merrick
garland talk
i know that's what's going to happen
here here's lawrence tribe
of course i'm not even going to read
that garbage i know where that's going
um and we have spero agnes ghost here
breaking in this ruling against trump's
attorney john eastman the judge says
it's more than likely that not that
trump committed crimes including felony
obstruction of congress on 1 6 the judge
blatantly described their behavior as
attempt of coup in search of legal
theory
in other words it's all [ __ ] they
were just trying they were just throwing
spaghetti at the
at the wall here the cheeto dust
spaghetti at the wall right
um so this is the breaking news uh you
know what we have someone here uh that
might be able to give us a little bit of
uh
insight into this breaking news um
if she is she ready
is she ready to join us are you can you
give me a thumbs up yeah
rachel bitcoffer hey rachel how are you
ah dude i'm pretty pretty excited how
about you oh i i i just we're just
seeing this breaking news um on the show
here
we were talking of course you know we
were talking about the slapper around
the world but this slap is the one that
has to be heard around the world
and uh maybe maybe just maybe if we talk
about will smith and chris rock enough
and then follow it up with this uh
people here you know i actually i
actually i think i i sent you some stuff
earlier saying uh people think thinking
that you can't talk about will smith and
chris rock in the context of what's
happening in our country is what's wrong
with liberals like liberals in this
country don't understand like
republicans in the right have bonded
like welded pop culture and their
politics together and that's the left
misses they don't they don't understand
that you can do two things at once and
you should weld these things together
because that's how we get people to pay
attention to things like i don't know
government and politics otherwise they
don't know who the vice president is
they don't know who the attorney general
is they don't know that there's a
federal case being had against john
eastman the the the the architect of the
cheeto dust kangaroo which and in this
statement right here in this slap heard
around the world from the judge which
should be the slap heard around the
world uh will smith if you're listening
this judge did a hell of a lot better
job of slapping john eastman donald
trump that you ever could dream of of
slapping chris rock on stage
but here's what i'll tell you here's
what i'll tell you um john eastman and
not only john eastman is implicated it
looks like in this judge's decision but
also donald trump as well they they
stopped short of saying condition
seditious conspiracy here um as i
noticed but they are uh very strongly
pointing towards that these are
these are felonies these are crimes and
they should be convicted of these crimes
um do you think that this is maybe you
know that we get a lot of fodder from
people saying oh the department of
justice and merrick garland aren't doing
their jobs and that's all anti-democracy
talk because i think when you when when
you as a pro-democracy person disparage
an institution and a person like merrick
garland you are doing democracy
disservice you're actually on the side
of autocracy when you want some one
person to have a magic wand to prosecute
anyone anywhere whenever you want for
whatever you want there is due process
in this country regardless i mean
our justice system isn't perfect and we
know there's a lot of problems that need
to be fixed but for for anyone out there
to take the the uh uh um the
authoritarian stance on the department
of justice is not doing democracy a
favor but i actually believe that this
this is groundbreaking like this is the
the
possible s the first nail in donald
trump's coffin here for january 6
because he's got a lot of other problems
with his business in new york and
possible voter voter intimidation
georgia this here is a problem that is
going to be huge because there's
something they're hiding don't you think
tony damn you're in fine form and nobody
here would know you spent all weekend
puking your balls off well that's true i
i was i was i did have a little stomach
bug this weekend but it was like the 24
hour thing so i'm going to that's my
favorite kind because at least you have
the clock right that's right that's
right and it happened and it happened
over the weekend so
couldn't have been perfect for my
saturday that was good timing yeah i
like the weekend stomach flu too because
i can't afford to miss a monday through
friday that's right that's right i can't
either two hours every single day right
here nobody else to do your [ __ ] for you
and neither do i okay
so tell us tell us why you think this is
so big
this is huge it is the slap heard around
the world and you know what's really
[ __ ] up about it guys all this all
y'all audience too is to understand that
i just randomly picked john eastman out
today when i tweeted that [ __ ] out dude
i was like oh wouldn't it be nice if
will smith had smack john eastman
because then people would actually know
who the [ __ ] he is
right right
a serendipity that like here's three
hours later and this [ __ ] big ass
news comes out about eastman and it
really does it is the slap and tony
you're absolutely right like i i try to
be uniform about it i don't i'm not
always great sometimes i'll celebrate
something i feel guilty about later you
know like a crowd interrupting a speaker
just because they're yelling [ __ ]
fascism or whatever you know and no
one's perfect but at the end of the day
i do try to always keep people's comment
to keep people to understand like listen
dude the justice department isn't going
to just come out with their dick
swinging and leave it over in the air if
you want to make a case especially these
kinds of cases which will be litigated
in a there's no precedent for this
litigation
probably the closest [ __ ] thing you
could think of would be john adams
defending the the boston massacre you
know soldiers before under an old system
of government because this is just
really
very it's it's taking the doj into a
realm it's not been in before and i and
i i do want people to understand like
when you
say things about the process or that
he's corrupt i mean i i wanted some
attention to go on brag and i think that
he's a fool to not [ __ ] uh let the
indictments and the grand juries go on
in manhattan but i don't think it's
because he's getting money from donald
trump right i think it's just that he
doesn't have the political balls to go
to town with this kind of stuff so you
know
which there's processes in new york that
that that the governor has to make sure
that if if that if that indictment needs
to happen in new york the governor of
new york has the ability to make that
indict not make it happen but to make
sure there's someone there that has the
as you say political balls to to uh seek
that indictment if there was crimes
committed especially against the state
in new york the governor has the right
now not only that is that tish james is
bringing a civil lawsuit that is um for
people to know tis james is the one that
handy that kneecap the trump foundation
right yeah she basically brought it down
like like the trump casino um
when it when it came down crashing to
the ground
and she's going to do the same thing her
mission is do the same thing to the
trump organization and the reason why is
because it's a total [ __ ] fraud he is
a fraud his business is a fraud him
being a billionaire is a [ __ ] fraud
his
his support is a fraud we've seen that
over the weekend with the trump rally
which i i don't mean to go all the way
back to the trump rally but let me tell
you i actually i actually think that
that trump rally has a lot to do with
this decision that's being made today
and the reason why is because donald
trump is hell-bent on the american
people believing that he's going to run
in 2024 now regardless if he does
because they definitely don't want to
make the conversation right now about
2022 they want to make it about 2024.
that is clear i mean some of the
despicable vile [ __ ] that was spewed
at that rally this weekend um not only
is
just disgusting
but some of the [ __ ] that came out of
marjory taylor green's mouth no doubt
and if you're if you're not aware
that that the fascists are coming after
you they're they're right around the
corner for you they're coming after
[ __ ] bicycles for crying out loud if
your kid rides a bike they're coming
after your [ __ ] kid with a bicycle
they hate bicycles they're the liberal
enemy now but i'll tell you that i think
i think that their their mission is to
distract their voters and their
constituency from things like this that
they were trying to overthrow the
government they were the ones trying to
commit a coup they were the ones that
are trying to install a dictator and it
and all this fodder about joe biden
somehow
you know the the world's sleepiest
mastermind i don't i can't understand
this [ __ ] um but he's the world's
sleepiest mastermind is all nonsense and
they're trying to distract their
constituency their vote because that's
all they've got that's all they've got
because it's only going to peel away
from the country as they discover
that john eastman and donald trump
conspired as a judge here says
coup in search of a legal theory which
is uh a choice of words i believe that
is a that is that is the quote right
there right and if i hadn't been driving
i would have already tweeted that quote
because it's just i mean it just says it
all right i mean this is a coup
in search of a legal rationale
right right yeah what well it was from
the beginning and really um they they
had a lot of straws that they were
trying to draw from right they were
trying to do the whole a supreme court
is going to decide this and making crown
a king
they tried inside the state the state
legislators to try to have alternative
electors which is probably going to
people go to federal prison
the extent and the complexity of this
plot across not only all three branches
of government as the jenny thomas and uh
stuff
you know makes clear so it's not just
the federal legislative and judicial
federal
par executive uh branches of the federal
government what we're talking about then
is the that's that goes down into all of
these state parties right especially in
the most um pivotal states georgia
arizona michigan pennsylvania wisconsin
uh arizona if i didn't say that it those
that criminal conspiracy
is so widespread that i i have long
argued that that there is no choice but
for doj to pursue the rule of law here
because to put it aside and say oh well
it's in the past like george bush's
torture stuff
there's no america if if this poo plot
because it's so extensive so it's so
intentional it is you know put into
checks multiple checks to try to
overthrow the election as you were just
talking about
it is a such a travesty of rule of law
that america cannot exist without
enforcement of the law here right right
well and and i i bel i believe they are
doing that because we we not only i mean
to say the department of justice is
sitting on their hands is a little
ridiculous they started from the actual
literal bottom of
of the conspiracy and have charged and
people are have their bare feet on a
cold floor in a prison right now
who broke windows at the capitol who
physically broke the windows at the
capitol for people who can spy or the
people who conspired to overturn our
government and [ __ ] on our constitution
and tear it and shred it into pieces and
make us a fascist state and they still
want to do that folks they're not done
they're not done with the coup they're
still there they what did we watch matt
gatt stand on stage to introduce the
cheeto dust mobster himself this weekend
and say that he want a sex trafficker an
accused sex trafficker by the way is
going to nominate a [ __ ] grabber for
the speaker of the house and he is proud
of it and donald trump came up and went
wow that's [ __ ] crazy even donald
trump was like
that's [ __ ] insane he couldn't even
believe that matt gatz was saying that
[ __ ] and that's only because
listen because only because he is mostly
unstrategic but he's not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right and so like the one thing that
he's wanted like people not to talk
about it and this is why i always talk
about it is the fact that he intends to
become speaker of the house he has no
other play that can possibly keep him
insulated from legal stuff no other
access point back into the public debate
and that's what he wants more than any
[ __ ] thing right probably over legal
immunity he wants to be in that position
right we're happy where he can't be
siloed out like uh in uh you know
superman out into that world
in space like that's basically where
donald trump exists in the one [ __ ]
thing he cares about which is attention
right and so um the last thing he needed
was mccarthy being reminded of that
vulnerability right now why he's puppet
stringing him and i'm sure donald trump
was at that moment thinking that
well and and i i i actually think that
it would it would cause a bunch of uh
disruption in donald trump's ego to go
from president of speaker the house but
i think if he could be convinced like
you're saying that he would be insulated
he would totally take he would totally
take that downgrade um and do that
there's literally nothing better for egg
if you think about being him and he's
just an evil [ __ ] up little con man
then think about like what that would
afford him then he can introduce
[ __ ] fake impeachment charges
against um oh it would be an onslaught
and and granted granted even if it would
happen i'm not saying that our country
would lose which we would lose badly um
but i am saying that we we would abs
think about how [ __ ] irresponsible
and how lazy that piece of [ __ ] is we
would the house of representatives would
come to a full stop of nothing nothing
would get done we wouldn't appropriate
any funds our government would fall our
credit rating would fall
regardless tony i mean people need to
[ __ ] understand with the republican
party takes control of the house of
representatives they just plowed through
500 000 people excess in covet deaths so
that they could attack democrats and
attack joe biden and undermine the
coveted response once bitem was sworn in
and the vaccine came out they will not
stop right and they it doesn't matter if
it's mccarthy
mtg
uh paul gosar donald trump i mean it
doesn't [ __ ] matter whoever that next
speaker is do not expect government to
function
right well they don't want government
that's the whole point like they don't
want it because their goal is to spark a
crisis right democracy is bad for them
just like in ukraine democracy is bad
for putin that's why they love putin
that's why they love the putin on the
world stage and that's why they hate
democracy and that's why they say [ __ ]
like we're not a democracy we're a
republic we are a constitutional
democratic republic we are a [ __ ]
democracy get a dictionary out dust that
son of a [ __ ] off and read the
definitions to words rachel thanks for
joining us we are at the end of the show
i appreciate you coming in beautiful
beautiful beautiful we love when you
join us everyone tomorrow join us again
live on youtube twitter twitch and now
on the facebook uh midas touch facebook
page noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific don't miss it every single
weekday monday through friday until
tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking